>> Tucker: YOU HAVE TO WONDER
HOW MANY HOURS WE SPENT
ATTACKING THE COMMUNIST PARTY OF
CHINA.
THAT ULTIMATELY KUBRICK NERVOUS
BUT THAT HAS BEEN OUR POSITION
AND THAT IS STILL OUR POSITION
QUICK AND THEY WANT TO BE AS
HONEST AS POSSIBLE.
WHEN THE CHINESE BECAUSE --
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T SOMETHING
VIRTUOUS.
HERE'S WHAT THEY HAVE DONE.
TURN IT ANNOUNCED IT WILL LIMIT
PRIVATE EQUITY FIRMS FROM
RAISING MONEY.
WHAT IS THAT CHINESE CITIZENS
TURNED OUT NEED SOMEWHERE TO
LIVE.
REAL ESTATE BUBBLES ARE BAD FOR
EVERYBODY EXCEPT, OF COURSE, FOR
A SMALL NUMBER OF REAL ESTATE
SPECULATORS.
AS THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT PUT IT
KEPT HOUSES ARE PERFECT LIVING
IN COULD NOT FOR SPECULATION.
THEY MAY HAVE LEARNED FROM
WATCHING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE AVERAGE HOME IS NOW OVER
$800,000 IN.
THANKS TO SPECULATION AND
HOMELESSNESS IS TOTALLY OUT OF
CONTROL.
THE CHINESE DON'T WANT TO COVER
THAT MODEL.
ONE THAT WORSHIPS CELEBRITY OVER
ACHIEVEMENT.
OBSESSING OVER SLEAZY FAMOUS
PEOPLE ON SOCIAL MEDIA, CHINESE
OFFICIAL ANNOUNCED THAT IS
"POISONING THE MINDS OF THE
COUNTRY'S YOUTH."
CANDIDATE STOP THAT YOUTH FROM
WORSHIPING CELEBRITIES?
PROBABLY NOT, BUT AT LEAST THEY
ARE RIGHT ABOUT IT.
THEY ARE ALSO WORRIED ABOUT
VIDEO GAMES IN CHINA.
ONLY GAMING WILL BE LIMITED TO
THE BEACONS.
THIS IS BEING DONE THAT THE
GOVERNMENT SAYS, "TO PREVENT THE
ADDICTION TO ONLINE GAMES."
IS THAT A CRAZY IDEA?
ACCORDING TO A RECENT STUDY IN
THIS COUNTRY, THE AVERAGE
AMERICAN KID PLAYS VIDEO GAMES
FOR MORE THAN 15 HOURS A WEEK.
THE POINT FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
MICHIGAN FOUND 80 PER SIX -- 80
PER SPACE%.
SO IT IS IN THE GENTLEMAN
PROBLEM.
FOR WHAT IS INTERESTING IS WHAT
WAS LEFT OF YOU HEARD ONE OF OUR
POLITICAL LEADERS EVEN MENTIONED
VIDEO GAMES OR HOUSING MARKET
SPECULATION WORK CELEBRITY
WORSHIP AS A PROBLEM?
NOW, BEFORE YOU RESPOND TO
SAYING, POLITICIANS SHOULD NOT
BE INVOLVED IN OUR PERSONAL
LIVES, REMEMBER THAT THE CDC
ALREADY PRETTY MUCH IS INVOLVED
IN OUR PERSONAL LIVES.
SUBMIT BE A GOVERNMENT CAN TAKE
JUST A MOMENT FROM BOSSING US
AROUND TO IMPROVE OUR ACTUAL
LIVES ONCE IN A WHILE.
JUST GO AHEAD AND TRY.
EVEN I